pour aider les canadiens qui veulent
acheter une première maison
le fédéral fait deux choses d'abord il
bonifie le régime d'accession à la
propriété qui permet d'utiliser ses airs
sans être pénalisé ensuite ottawa vous
propose de vous prêter de l'argent sans
intérêt je pense que ce que nous voulons
ainsi être fait à se dire on veut pas
accroître l'endettement des ménages
pour être admissible au près votre
revenu familial doit être inférieur à
120 mille dollars pour comprendre
comment fonctionne l'aide le
gouvernement fédéral donne l'exemple
suivant disons que vous achetez une
maison évaluée à 400 mille dollars avec
une mise de fonds de 5 %
normalement vous allez devoir rembourser
une hypothèque de 380 mille dollars
si vous choisissez d'acheter une maison
toute neuve la société canadienne
d'hypothèques et de logement va assumer
10% de la valeur de la maison sur une
maison de 400 lits ça signifie un prêt
de 40 mille dollars
il restera donc 340 millions de dollars
d'hypothèques à rembourser au lieu de
380000 et selon à savoir il s'agit d'une
économie de 228 $ par mois
s'intéressant pas reconduit reste
beaucoup de questions dans la mécanique
exact si vous achetez une maison
existante
le prêt de la schl sera toutefois de 5 %
donc de 20 mille dollars et vous restera
369 $ d'hypothèques à rembourser cet
argent là c'est pas un cadeau
donc les forcément faut comprendre que
le jour où on vend la propriété le vin
est mis à l'eau à 40 mais qui était
financé par l'institut lasers ou pour ça
c'est quand même l'équité qu'on doit
rendre à la schl
ensemble le prêt de la schl et votre
hypothèque ne doivent pas excéder quatre
fois votre revenu familial comme le
revenu familial le maximum est fixé à
120 mille dollars
oh pardon d'un plafond de 480 mille
dollars 488 $ c'est beaucoup d'argent
mais c'est bien en dessous du prix moyen
d'une maison à vancouver qui s'élève à
environ 1 million $ ou encore à toronto
ou une maison coûte en moyenne sept cent
soixante sept mille dollars
en fait avec un plafond de 480 mille
dollars
le programme du fédéral sera sûrement
plus accessible dans une région comme le
grand montréal où là
à leur moyenne tourne autour de 330
mille dollars c'est clair leçon gamme
québec chaque groupe
winnipeg les villes plus petites
magloire à 400 mille cinq cent mille il
existe deux propriétés évidemment
vancouver à toronto puis à montréal
il faut s'éloigner un petit peu tous ces
mesures d'accès à la propriété les
entreront en vigueur en septembre
prochain soit quelques semaines à peine
avant les élections ici vincent
maisonneuve réseau canada montréal